Навпроти мене Євгеній Мураєв, позафракційний депутат Верховної Ради України,
кандидат у президенти України і лідер політичної партії "Наші".
Євгенію, дякую за інтерв'ю. Ласкаво просимо в програму.
Дякую за запрошення.
Трохи більше п'яти років тому почалися масові протести на Майдані,
і ставлення до Майдану - це певна розмежувальна лінія для всіх українських політиків.
Де Ви були під час протестів?
Я був у Києві, я не був учасником протистояння ні з одного, ні з іншого боку.
Я взагалі негативно ставлюся до будь-яких подібних форм демократії.
Демократія - дуже складне слово і, по суті, ключ від цього поняття - у Вашингтоні.
І тільки вони мають право вирішувати - мирні це протести чи державний переворот.
І таким чином встановлюють необхідні їм режими та світову демократію. Я категорично проти.
Ви проти мітингів загалом чи саме проти Майдану?
Я проти державних переворотів. Я проти насильницької зміни влади.
Можна безкінечно говорити про те, що це був мирний протест, але нині правди вже не приховати.
І під час справи беркутівців, і інших, і під час суду над Януковичем розкривається дуже багато фактів:
і захоплення адмінбудівель, і злочини, і більше тисячі міліціонерів, які постраждали,
деякі з них загинули - це все не може називатися мирним протестом.
Крім того...
А скажіть, це провина протестувальників чи це провина тих людей,
які на той момент очолювали країну,
зокрема й особисто колишнього президента України Віктора Януковича?
Безумовно, він не зміг зберегти конституційний лад, забезпечити правопорядок.
Безумовно, є і "вигодоотримувачі", які в результаті цих смертей стали владою.
Але я думаю, глобальна привина, звісно ж, на тих, хто гарантував мир в Україні -
це посли європейських держав і Сполучені Штати, які надавали цьому форму мирного протесту,
але не помічали очевидних правопорушень,
котрі були спрямовані на повалення конституційного ладу.
У скільки приблизно обходиться в середньому виборча кампанія в Україні?
Це дуже складне питання.
Ну якийсь діапазон цін є, ну приблизно, щоб таку нормальну кампанію провести...
За найскромнішими підрахунками, щоб дійсно спробувати протистояти фальсифікаціям
і підтасовкам результатів виборів - для кандидата це буде коштувати
близько десяти мільйонів доларів на добу.
Плюс агітація. Це засоби масової інформації, друкований матеріал, робота агітаторів.
Вони можуть працювати як волонтери, а можуть працювати за заробітну плату.
У серйозних кандидатів, які мають адмінресурс,
я маю на увазі насамперед чинного президента України,
існує мережа, сформована з виконавчої вертикалі влади, тобто обласні та районні адміністрації,
його представництва в органах влади.
Тобто їм, напевно, це коштує дешевше плюс адмінресурс.
Інші кандидати за це повинні платити, формуючи районні, обласні організації.
Але загалом, я думаю, що йдеться все одно про мільйони, десятки мільйонів,
а якщо претендуєш на серйозні позиції, це, напевно, обчислюється в сотнях.
Тому щоб донести ідеологію, достукатися до кожного виборця,
можна тільки за допомогою великих телеканалів,
на які мене зазвичай не пускають.
Зараз момент, коли я буду зареєстрований як кандидат, буду тоді...
Ну давайте скажемо, що у Вас є свій канал.
Це не мій телеканал.
"Наш"?
Скажімо так, я маю стосунок до нього.
Компанія, яка належить батькові, надала обладнання для колективу,
який у принципі був кістяком телеканалу, яким я володів.
Це був телеканал NewsOne, і вони створили новий інформаційний майданчик.
Я думаю, це трохи більше, ніж телебачення. Але на жаль, поки що...
Ну, у Вас з батьком хороші стосунки.
З хлопцями?
З батьком, який є засновником.
Безумовно, а у кого з батьками погані стосунки.
Ну, Ви кажете, що формально не Вам належить, але вашому батьку, значить...
І формально, і юридично, і безумовно.
У мене колись був бізнес, тепер він за законом повністю належить моїй родині.
Як у держслужбовця ще з 10-го року у мене тільки один вид діяльності -
служіння людям і державі Україна.
Тобто займатися бізнесом і щось курирувати я не міг.
Володіти корпоративними правами я міг.
Але потім ухвалили закон про те, що й корпоративні права мають бути в управлінні когось.
Тому я просто передав їх сімї - це лоігчно, я це створював багато років.
Ось Ви назвали досить значні суми для виборчої кампанії - десятки мільйонів доларів.
І при цьому кажете, що в Україні сформована така олігархічна або кланова система,
що є кілька сімей, які контролюють більшу частину ВВП країни.
Хто вас підтримує з промислово-фінансових кіл?
Досить багато. Незабаром ви їх  побачите.
Просто на сьогодні у нас дуже небезпечно бути опозиційними політиками
і бути членами опозиційних партій.
Дуже багато провокацій, багато гоніннь, кримінальних справ.
Євгенію, Ви, як мені здається, висловлюєте таку точку зору - політичну та ідеологічну,
яка досить поширена в Росії.
Чому я кажу про Росію. Бо Ви потрапили до санкційного списку.
Ось останній список, і раптом там опинилося Ваше ім'я. Чому?
Це не я. Якщо Ви помітили, було кілька курйозних ситуацій зі списками.
В сенсі?
Якщо пам'ятаєте, в перший список санкцій потрапив Карась -
однофамілець активіста праворадикальної організації.
Ну, там переплутали імена і по-батькові.
І в результаті потрапив галерист, а не та, людина, яка реально є представником фашистської ідеології.
Я потрапив у цей список, тільки я чомусь виявився 67-го року народження, а не 76-го.
І народився я в населеному пункті, якого в Україні не існує.
А існує ця людина, яка ваш повний тезка?
Ні, звичайно. Просто я 1976 року народження, а в санкційних списках чомусь 67-ий.
Я народився в місті Зміїв, а там Змієв.
Тобто такі, знаєте, якісь дуже смішні помилки, які не можуть характеризувати спецслужбу як професійну.
Скоріш за все, його похапцем писали на коліні, можливо, навіть у телефонному режимі.
У нас серед політиків побутує думка, що його написали в адміністрації президента Порошенка
рукою Медведчука.
Бо, по суті, це була розправа з політичними опонентами, які заважали формулі,
коли Порошенко і Бойко зустрічаються в другому турі.
Бо Бойко - єдиний кандидат, який представляє якусь іншу, відмінну від влади ідеологію,
а саме Бойко програє Порошенку в другому турі.
Я зрозуміла, попри ті помилки, яких припустилися, ви в цьому списку і не можете їздити в Росію.
Дивіться, там же економічні санкції.
У мене абсолютно нічого немає в Росії: ні виробництв, ні рахунків у банках.
Тобто мене ці санкції не зачіпають.
Але цілком можливо, це ще й забороняє в'їзд або принаймні ускладнює.
Якщо ви провели в аеропорту дві з половиною години, то я, можливо, просиджу набагато більше.
Я дивилася багато Ваших інтерв'ю, читаю Ваш Фейсбук,
Ви пишете і виступаєте публічно тільки російською мовою.
Це Ваша принципова позиція чи існують якісь інші об'єктивні причини,
що Ви недостатньо добре володієте українською мовою, щоб публічно виступати?
По-перше, я представник південного сходу, я російськомовний українець.
Я прекрасно володію українською мовою, і ви це побачите під час кампанії.
Я дуже негативно ставлюся до всіх форм утисків і тиску.
На сьогодні саме російськомовна частина населення зазнає тиску
і, по суті, є пригніченою в багатьох правах.
Якщо ви звернете увагу, які закони останнім часом ухвалила ця недокоаліція,
то побачите, що триває повномасштабний наступ на культурні цінності,
близькі людям, які проживають в принципі у всіх частинах України,
але, скажімо так, не є титульною нацією.
Важко заперечувати, що сьогодні націоналістичні настрої в Україні досить слабкі,
але зведені, напевно, до рангу обов'язкової ідеології.
І президент, і парламент, і глава парламенту, і в принципі кабінет міністрів,
по суті, цю ідеологію навіть заохочують.
Тобто я правильно розумію, що це Ваша принципова позиція. Це демонстрація...
Демонстрація протесту - це раз. І це моє право.
І у мене його ніхто не забере. Це право мені гарантоване, по-перше, Конституцією.
Воно чітко там прописане.
А по-друге, вам треба бути російськомовним українцем, щоб відчути те,
що ми всі сьогодні відчуваємо.
Україна завжди вибирала то західний шлях, то була з Росією.
Це так яскраво почалося в 17 столітті…
Комплекс молодшого брата.
Не буду коментувати те, що Ви сказали. Це Ви сказали.
Як Ви вважаєте, який повинен бути ціннісний вибір України?
Це повинна бути все ж країна, в якій переважають європейські цінності,
про які Ви кажете, до яких Ви так чи інакше апелюєте:
свобода ЗМІ і вільні вибори, всі ці цінності.
Чи Україна повинна йти якимось своєрідним - третім, я не знаю, четвертим шляхом?
Перед Україною ніколи не стояв цивілізаційний вибір.
Нас ніколи насправді не чекала Європа.
І ось ці політики, які сьогодні керують державою, просто обдурили,
по суті, все населення, кажучи, що підписання договору про асоціацію
означає вступ до Євросоюзу.
Я вважаю, що це абсолютно шкідливий для нас документ, оскільки він, по суті,
відібрав експортний потенціал у наших товаровиробників,
відкрив внутрішній ринок для товарів, які виробляються в Європі,
підірвав потенціал наших виробників та зробив їх неконкурентоспроможними.
Чи стоїть перед нами вибір
реалізувати ще раз комплекс молодшого брата в союзі з Росією чи з Європою?
Я вважаю, в України є третій шлях.
Ми повинні будувати свою державу самостійно і працювати з тими, з ким нам вигідно.
Нам вигідно працювати з Росією - значить з нею треба працювати.
Нам вигідно працювати з Європою - значить треба з нею працювати.
Якщо угода про асоціацію, її економічна частина, не відповідає нашим інтересам,
її треба або переглянути, або від неї відмовитись.
Тобто це швейцарський шлях?
Абсолютно точно. І іншого варіанту немає.
А якщо подивитися на світ, хто з політичних фігур Вам близький,
викликає у Вас знову симпатію, можливо, навіть захоплення?
Пропустимо це питання.
А чому?
Розумієте, будь-який політик зобов'язаний, в першу чергу, керуватися інтересами своєї країни,
і він повинен нехтувати своєю особистою думкою
і керуватися виключно благополуччям своїх громадян.
Тобто я розумію, що, в разі моєї перемоги,
мені доведеться вести переговори абсолютно з усіма державами,
які потрапляють в зону наших інтересів.
Ні, я не кажу про чинних, можна говорити і про минулих.
Про минулих?
Не про чинних ідеться, не обов'язково.
Мені подобаєся, напевно, Черчилль.
Мені подобалася Маргарет Тетчер. Мені подобаються сильні лідери, харизматичні.
Але знову ж таки - їх можна по-різному судити.
До Сталіна дуже багато запитань, але я прекрасно розумію,
який ривок зробив Радянський Союз під його керівництвом.
Згадуючи 37-й рік, 33-й і всі інші. До них усіх багато запитань.
Ну, напевно, максимальну ефективність треба ставити як рівень КДП якийсь певний.
Черчилль, Тетчер і Сталін?
Можливо, можливо. Але знову ж таки, це ж все перекрутять
і скажуть, що у мене симпатія до Сталіна, і будуть згадувати події, і репресії...
І всього іншого.
Ні, мені подобається ефективність керівництва, ще раз скажу.
Якщо країна від мотики полетіла в космос - це багато про що свідчить.
Велике спасибі і бажаю удачі.
Дякую.